uh
a personality
that we haven't seen like him
in our lifetime to be honest
is a person who sleeps every day only
two to three hours because of his work
and not many people can do that
mashallah he is down to earth person he
has photographic memory
that he would look at an article
and we'll memorize it straight away
within few minutes
he has biggest library in the world
can you guess who is
sorry can you guess again
dr zakir naik dr zakir abdul karim nayak
my respective elders
and my dear brothers and sisters i
welcome all of you
with the islamic greetings assalamu
alaikum
may peace
mercy
and blessings
of allah
almighty god
be on all of you
it's a pleasure and honor
for me
to give a speech
the concluding speech
of this conference
global peace and unity
the topic
of my talk is
islam
the only solution
for global peace
and unity
there are various different types
of unity
unity
based on blood relationships
based on regions
on race
on cast
on color
but all these unities
they are limited they are not global
islam does not agree
that the humankind has been divided
into different castes and different
levels
i started my talk
by quoting a verse from the glorious
quran
from surah hujarat
chapter number 49
verse number 13
we have created you from a single pair
of male and female and have divided you
into nations and tribes so that you
shall recognize each other not that you
shall despise each other and the most
honored in the sight of allah is the
person who has taqwa
the criteria for judgment
in the sight of allah subhana watala
it is not color it's not caste it's not
wealth it's not sex but it is taqwa it
is god consciousness it is piety it is
righteousness
allah says in the quran in surah
chapter number 30
verse number 22
amongst his signs he has created the
heavens and the earth
and
has created the variations
in your languages and color
so that it will be a sign for those who
know
allah has created humankind in different
colors
and has created different languages so
that
you may recognize each other
allah says in surah israel chapter
number 17 verse number 17
allah has honored all the humankind
irrespective whichever part of the world
you come from whichever community you
come from
allah has honored all the children of
adam the whole of humankind
allah says in surah chapter number 35
verse number 24
there is not a nation or a tribe to whom
we have not sent a warner
allah says in surah chapter number
thirteen verse number seven well equally
common
and to every nation we have sent a guide
almighty god has sent messengers to
every nation to every ummah
and our beloved prophet muhammad allah
said it's mentioned hadith of ahmed ibn
humble
volume number five a beloved prophet
said
there were 124 000 messengers sent on
the face of the earth
but all the messengers that came before
the last and final messenger prophet
muhammad peace be upon him they were
only sent for their people
for their ummah
but since prophet muhammad peace be upon
him was the last and final messenger he
was not sent only for the muslims or for
the arabs allah says in the quran in
surah chapter number 21 verse number 107
we have sent thee not but as a mercy to
all the worlds as a mercy to all the
creatures as a mercy to the whole of
humanity
we have not sent thee but as a universal
messenger
giving glad tidings and warning them
against sin but most of the humankind
yet do not know
so prophet muhammad peace be upon him
was not sent only for the muslims or for
the arabs he was sent for the whole of
humankind
allah says in surah chapter number 13
verse number 38
the kulli aj kitab in every age have we
sent a revelation
my name only four are mentioned in the
quran
but in every age almighty god has sent a
revelation
but all the revelation that came before
the last and final revelation the quran
they were only sent for their people and
the complete message was supposed to be
followed till a particular time period
but because the quran
is the last and final revelation allah
says in sorry ibrahim chapter number 14
verse number one
islam
this
is a book revealed to the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him so that thou
may lead us the humankind from darkness
to light because quran was the last and
final message from almighty god it was
not sent only for the muslims or for the
arabs it was sent for the whole of
humankind
and this message is repeated in surah
ibrahim chapter number 14 verse number
52 in surah baqarah chapter number 2
verse number 185 as well as surah azumar
chapter 39 verse number 41 that the
quran has been revealed for the whole of
humankind
if there is something like the old
testament and the new testament
this glorious quran is the last
testament for humankind
the cornerstone
of the islamic faith is
believe in one and only creator and
sustainer of the whole universe who only
deserves to be worshiped
this cornerstone of belief
in one and only creator and sustainer of
the universe is the only point
of unity
amongst the whole of humankind
and this is the only uniting factor for
the whole of humankind that we have got
one common parents and our creator our
sustainer our cherisher is only one and
he alone deserves to be worshipped
and if you read
the scriptures of the major world
religions they too emphasize on
monotheism on belief in one god
and this is the only uniting factor for
the whole of humankind for global unity
religion
according to the oxford dictionary means
a belief in a superhuman controlling
power a personal god or gods that
deserve worship and obedience
in short religion means
belief in god
allah says in the quran in surah
al-imran chapter number 3
verse number 64.
say o people of the book
come to common terms as
and you which is the first term
that we worship none but one almighty
god
that we associate the partners with him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and people other than allah
find the love if then they turn back
that we are muslims bowing our will to
allah
the strategy shown
that we worship none but one and only
almighty god to understand the concept
of god in religion we should not observe
what the followers of the religion do
to understand the concept of god in a
religion we have to try and understand
what the scriptures have to speak about
almighty god and if we analyze
the scriptures of the major world
religions they emphasize
on oneness of god on unity of god on
tahit
first we'll discuss
the concept of god in hinduism
if you ask the common hindu
that how many gods does believe in
some may say three
some will say thousand some will say 33
crores 330 million but if you ask a
learned hindu who is well versed with
the scriptures he will tell you that the
hindus should believe and worship only
one god
but the common hindu
he believes in the philosophy of
pantheism the common hindu says that
everything is god the tree is god
the sun is god the moon is god the human
being is god the snake is god what we
muslims say
everything is god's
g o d with an apostrophe s everything
belongs to god the tree belongs to god
the sun belongs to god the moon belongs
to god the human being belongs to god
the snake belongs to god so the major
difference between the hindu and the
muslim is the common hindu says
everything is god we muslims say
everything is god's g-o-d with an
apostrophe s if we can solve this
difference of apostrophe s the hindus
and the muslims will be united
how do you do it
as allah says
come to common terms as in us and you
which is the first term
that we worship none but one almighty
god
let's analyze what the hindu scriptures
have to speak about almighty god
among the sacred scriptures of hindus
is the chandogya upanishad which
mentions in chapter number six section
number two verse number one
it's a sanskrit quotation which means
god is only one without a second it's
mentioned in the shritas with our
upanishad
chapter number six verse number nine
which in sanskrit means of him of
almighty god he has got no lord he has
got no parents he has got no mother he
has got no father
it's mentioned in the shrita srita
upanishad chapter number 4 verse number
of him there is no likeness almighty god
has got no likeness
the most popular and widely read book
amongst hindu scriptures is the
bhagavad-gita it's mentioned
bhagavad-gita chapter number 7 verse
number 20.
all those whose intelligence has been
stolen by material desires they worship
demigods they do idle worship
it's mentioned in bhagavad-gita chapter
number 10 verse number three
they know me as the unborn
the one who's not begotten the supreme
lord of all the worlds
amongst the hindu scriptures the most
sacred are the vedas
of him there are no images almighty god
has got no images it's mentioned
chapter number 40 verse number nine
they are entering darkness those who
worship the asambhuti
the natural things like fire water air
etc and the verse continues they are
entering more in darkness those who
worship the sambhuti that is the created
things like table chair idols etc who
says that
yajurvede chapter number 32 verse number
three
it's mentioned rigveda book number one
hymn number 164 verse number 46
god is one truth is one sages call him
by a variety of names and there are no
less than 33 different attributes given
to almighty god in rigveda alone in book
number two him number one it's further
mentioned in rigveda book number eight
him number one verse number one machida
the sunset all praise is due to him
alone worship him alone
and the brahma sutra
the fundamental creed of hinduism
not a second one not at all not at all
not in the least bit
so if you read the hindu scriptures you
shall understand the concept of god in
hinduism that the fundamental teaching
is you should believe in one god who
does not have any images does not have
any idols and worship him alone
let's discuss the concept of god in
judaism
it's mentioned in the old testament in
the book of deuteronomy chapter number
six verse number four moses peace be
upon him said shama israel
it's a hebrew quotation which means euro
israel the lord our god is one lord
it's mentioned in the book of isaiah
chapter number 43 verse number 11
i am lord
and there's none else there is no savior
besides me
it's mentioned book of isaiah chapter
number 45 verse number five i am god and
there's none else there's no god besides
me it's mentioned the book of isaiah
chapter number 46 verse number nine i am
god and there's none like me
it's mentioned in the book of exodus
chapter number 20 verse number three to
five and the book of deuteronomy chapter
number five verse number seven to nine
it says almighty god says in the old
testament
thou shalt have no other god besides me
thou shalt not make unto thee any graven
image of anything of any likeness in
heaven above
in the earth beneath and the water
beneath the earth thou shalt not bow
down to them not serve them for i thy
god thy lord is a jealous god
so if you read the old testament you
shall understand the concept of god in
judaism which believes in only one god
who deserves to be worshipped and he has
got no images
before we discuss the concept of god in
christianity
let me make a few points clear islam is
the only non-christian faith which makes
it an article of faith to believe in
jesus christ peace be upon him no muslim
is a muslim
if he does not believe in jesus christ
peace be upon him
we believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of allah of
almighty god
we believe
that he was the messiah translated
christ we believe
that he was born miraculously without
any male intervention which many modern
day christians today do not believe we
believe that he gave life to the dead
with god's permission we believe that he
healed those born blind and lepers with
god's permission the muslim and the
christians we are going together
but one may ask then where is the
parting of ways
the parting of ways is there are many
christians who say that jesus christ
peace be upon him he claimed divinity he
said that he was almighty god
in fact
if you read the bible there is not a
single unequivocal statement in the
complete bible where jesus christ peace
be upon him himself says that i am god
or where he says worship me i would like
to repeat
in the complete bible if you read there
is not a single unambiguous statement
but jesus christ peace be upon him
himself says that i am god or where he
says worship me in fact if you read the
bible
jesus christ peace be upon him said it's
mentioned the gospel of john chapter
number 14 verse number 28 jesus christ
peace be upon him said my father is
greater than i
gospel of john chapter number 10 verse
number 29 my father is greater than all
gospel of matthew chapter number 12
verse number 28 i cast out devils with
the spirit of god gospel of luke chapter
number 11 verse number 20 i with the
finger of god cast out devils gospel of
john chapter number five verse number 30
i can of my own self do nothing
i can of my own self do nothing as i
hear i judge and my judgment is just for
i seek not my will but the will of my
father anyone who says i seek not my
will but the will of almighty god he's a
muslim jesus christ peace be upon
another muslim
it's mentioned in the book of acts
chapter number two
verse number 22 e men of israel listen
to this jesus of nazareth a man approved
of god amongst you by wonders and
miracles which god did by him and your
witness to it
a man approved of god amongst you by
wonders and miracles and signs which god
did by him and your witness to it
and when jesus christ was asked that
which is the first of the commandment he
repeated verbatim what was said by moses
peace be upon him it's mentioned the
gospel of mark chapter number 12 verse
number 29 and he said shema israel
euro israel the lord our god is one lord
so if you read the christian scriptures
the bible it too speaks about oneness of
god
who only deserves to be worshipped
let's discuss
the concept of god in islam
the best reply that any muslim can give
you
regarding the concept of allah is
there is nothing like him this is a four
line definition if any person says that
so and so can rate is god and if that
candidate fits in the four line
definition we muslims have got no
objection in accepting that candidate as
god the first is
second
allah
says allah one and only the absolute the
eternal
military he begets not noisy begotten
there's nothing like him
this suray class is the touchstone of
theology
whichever god you're worshiping put him
to the test of surah class if that
candidate passes the test we have no
objection in accepting that candidate as
allah as almighty god
allah says in the quran in surah israel
chapter number 17 verse 110.
stay call upon him
by whichever name you call upon him to
him belongs the most beautiful name
this concept
of believing
in one soul creator and sustainer of the
whole universe
the whole of mankind is the only uniting
factor for the whole of humankind
it is the only solution for the global
unity
islam does not only speak about unity it
practically demonstrates unity every day
in our life every muslim should
practically demonstrate unity at least
five times a day during our salah when
we muslims of a salah we stand shoulder
to shoulder irrespective of the person
staying next to you whether it's black
or white yellow or brown rich or poor
king or popper when you stand for salah
you have to stand shoulder shoulder
we muslims practically demonstrate
global unity at least once a year during
the hajj
in
hajj about two and a half million people
gather from different parts of the world
from usa from uk from canada from
singapore from malaysia from india from
pakistan from the arab countries and the
men they are dressed up in two pieces of
unsewn white cloth you cannot identify
whether the person standing next to you
is a king or a popper it is the best
example of annual global unity
our beloved prophet muhammad said
no arab
is superior to a non-arab
neither is a non-arab superior to an
arab
no white man is superior to a black man
neither is a black man superior to a
white man except by virtue except by
taqwa except by god consciousness except
by piety
so the only solution for the global
unity is believing and worshiping only
one soul creator and sustainer
now we proceed to the second part of the
talk that is global peace
islam is the only solution
for global peace
islam
comes
from the root word
which means peace it is also derived
from the arabic word
which means to submit your will to
almighty god in short islam means peace
acquired by submitting your will to
almighty god allah
and any person
who submits his will to almighty god is
called as a muslim
muslim by definition means a person who
has acquired peace
by submitting his will to allah to
almighty god
and this word islam
is mentioned in the quran no less than
eight times and the word
salam
a muslim
is mentioned in the quran no less than
45 times
that's the reason
the greetings
of the muslim is
assalamu alaikum
may peace be on you
and this was the greetings of all the
messengers of allah subhanahu ta'ala
including jesus christ peace be upon him
if you read the bible when jesus christ
peace be upon him goes to the upper room
in the gospel of luke chapter number 24
verse number 36
he says shalom
in hebrew in arabic assalamu
in english may peace be on you
this is the best global salutation of
peace assalamu alaikum may peace be on
you
unfortunately
today the western world
the majority of which
adheres to the faith of christianity
they use a different form of greeting
good morning
good afternoon good evening hi hello
why don't they use the greetings of
jesus christ peace be upon him may peace
be on all of you
[Applause]
islam
is religion of peace
but unfortunately today we find in the
international media
there is virulent propaganda about islam
the international media
it is bombarding misinformation about
islam to the world
and
according to an article
which came in the time magazine
on the 16th of april 1979
it says
that
there were more than 60 000 books
written against islam and against the
prophet in a span of 150 years from 1800
to 1950 if you calculate more than one
book was written against islam
every day
but after 9 11
after 11 september 2001
this has reached epidemic levels now
the percentage the number has increased
to epidemic levels
it is the duty of every muslim
that he tries and clarifies
these misconceptions
that are spread
by the media
and the media adopts
certain strategies it's portraying as
though islam is a religion which causes
unrest which is the cause of the
disruption of peace in the world
the strategies they use is one of them
that
they say such things belong to islam
which are alien to islam
it is unheard of in islam for example
they say
that islam is an outdated religion it's
a religion which does not believe in
recent logic and science
in fact islam is the most up-to-date
religion it believes in recent logic and
science and you can refer to my video
cassette quran and modern science
conflict or conciliation
the other strategy used by the media is
they quote many verses of the quran and
the hadith out of context
i'll give you one example
the media says
the quran mentions
chapter number nine
verse number five that wherever you find
the kafir into bracket non-muslim you
kill him
and if you open the quran you will find
this verse it does say wherever you find
the kafir kill him
but they're quoting this verse out of
context
the context is it is a verse which was
revealed in the battlefield and allah
says that when the enemies come to fight
you don't get scared
have courage and kill them it's in the
battlefield they're coding out of
context
any army general today to boost up the
morale of his soldiers he will but
naturally say that when you find the
enemy don't get scared kill him he will
not say that just sit quiet
and
many a time after quoting surat oba
chapter 9 verse number 5 they jump to
verse number 7. why because verse number
six has the reply
verse number six says that if the enemy
wants peace
don't just give it to him escort him to
a place of security
imagine
the most merciful army general today the
maximum he will say is let the enemy go
but the quran says don't just let him go
escort him to a place of security so
that he may hear the word of almighty
god
there are various such examples suryan 5
chapter number 8 verse number 60 where
talks
about killing the enemy but immediately
next was most of the time in the quran
when it speaks about killing the enemy
immediately the next verse speaks about
peace it says in surah anfal chapter
number 8 verse number 61 that peace is
better if the enemy wants peace give it
to them
this is what the quran says
so quran and islam is for peace they
quote verses out of context
the third strategy used is
that
they pick up black sheeps of the
community and they portray as though the
exemplary muslim
i would like to ask a question
suppose you want to judge how good is
the latest mercedes car
500 sel
and if a person who does not know how to
drive the car sits behind the steering
wheel and he bangs up the car who will
you blame will you blame the car or will
you blame the diver
who will you blame the car the driver
but naturally the driver
if you want to know how good the car is
you look at the specification what is it
speed what is the safety measure what is
the pickup how many gears it has got etc
and if you really want to test drive the
car put behind the steering wheel an
expert driver if you want to judge islam
look at the exemplary muslim which is
the last and final prophet prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
the last strategy they say that islam
is the problem for humankind
actually islam is the solution to the
problems of humankind
the media says that muslims are
fundamentalist
what is the meaning of fundamentalists
fundamentalist means a person who
follows the fundamentals of one
particular subject
if a person
wants to be a good doctor he should know
follow and practice the fundamentals of
medicine unless he's the fundamentalist
in the field of medicine he can't be a
good doctor
if a person wants to be a good scientist
he should know follow and practice the
fundamentals of science unless he's a
fundamentalist in the field of science
he cannot be a good scientist
you have to first check up in which
field the person is a fundamentalist as
far as i am concerned i am proud to be a
fundamentalist muslim
because i know
and i strive to follow the fundamentals
of islam and i know there is not a
single fundamental of islam which is
against humanity as a whole i challenge
anyone to point out a single fundamental
of islam which is against humanity as a
whole
if you read the definition in the oxford
dictionary of the word fundamentalist it
says fundamentalist is a person who
strictly adheres to the teachings of the
ancient doctrine of any religion but
when i read a revised edition of oxford
dictionary there's a slight change it
says that fundamentally is the person
who strictly adheres to the teachings of
the ancient doctrine of any religion
especially islam
the moment you are the fundamentalist
you start thinking of a muslim
you start thinking as an extremist
i tell the people i am an extremist
i'm extremely kind i'm extremely loving
i'm extremely peaceful i'm extremely
merciful
what's wrong in being an extremist
why are we apologetic turn the tables
over can any human being tell me it is
wrong to be extremely honest it's wrong
to be extremely kind it's wrong to be
extremely peaceful it's wrong to be
extremely just
they give us the label that muslims are
terrorists
and we find that in history many a times
two different labels are given to the
same activity of the same person
we have the example that in india
more than 60 years back there were many
people who were fighting for the freedom
of the country
when the british government was ruling
india these people were called by the
british government as terrorists
but we common indians we call them
freedom fighters as patriots same people
same activity two different labels if
you agree with the view of the british
government that they had the right to
rule india you have to call them
terrorists but if you agree with the
view of the common indians that the
britishers came to india to business
they have no right to know us then you
would call them freedom fighters as
patriots we see the example of american
revolution in the 18th century the
british government when they were ruling
america 18th century there were many
americans were fighting for the freedom
benjamin franklin george washington by
this british government they were called
as terrorist number one
america got its freedom in 1775-76
later on george washington becomes the
first president of usa imagine terrorist
number one becomes the president of usa
the same george washington he happens to
be the godfather of all the presidents
of usa to come including george bush
and today
this government is very friendly with
the terrorist government why
why
first you have to try and find out for
what reason the person is driving
the media says islam is an intolerant
religion i say yes islam is an
intolerant religion islam is intolerant
towards injustice islam is intolerant
towards dishonesty islam is intolerant
towards corruption
islam is intolerable towards racism
towards discrimination
islam is intolerant towards the social
things which the westerners enjoy islam
is intolerant towards drug addiction
towards alcoholism towards prostitution
towards fornication towards adultery
i dr zakir naik say that islam is an
intolerant religion
intolerant towards the evil of the
society
why are we afraid why are we afraid to
call ourselves muslims
alhamdulillah it is the most tolerant
religion for spreading peace that's the
reason today the superpowers of the
world they're afraid
i'm talking about the politicians
they're afraid of islam because this is
the only religion that can bring peace
in the world
and these superpowers these politicians
they fear their seat that if islam
spread they will lose their seat they
will lose their vote bank they are
afraid of islam
today the media says that islam was fed
by the sword
delasio o'leary writes in his book he
was a famous historian he says that
history makes it clear that the legend
of fanatical muslims sweeping across the
world forcing islam at the point of the
sword is the most fantastic myth that
historian ever repeated
there was a survey done in the plane
through magazine in 1986 the increase in
the world religion in a span of 50 years
from 1934 to 1984 and number one
religion was islam 235
christianity only 47
islam 235 percent
which war took place between 1934
and 1984 which converted hundreds and
thousands of people to islam today the
fastest growing religion in america is
islam the fastest growing religion in
europe is islam
[Applause]
the media says that islam subjugates
women if islam subjugates women out of
those people accepting islam the
non-muslims the americans the europeans
two third of them are women why are
these american women why are the
european women accepting islam if islam
subjugates them
the reason is because these american
women these european women they find the
solution to the problem that they have
in islam
after 11 september
after 11 september in a span of
10 months only in america 34 000
americans accepted islam
in the span of nine months
in europe 22 000 europeans accepted
islam allah says in surah al-imran
chapter 3 verse 54.
how much
however much the media is against islam
the more they try to subjugate islam the
more they try to suppress islam
inshallah islam will spread more
allah gives a promise in the quran in no
less than three different places in
surah chapter 9 verse number 33 in surah
chapter number 48 verse number 28 and
surah chapter number 61 verse number 9
[Music]
allah has sent his messenger with truth
and the religion of so that will prevail
over all the other religions over all
their ism whether it be christianism
judaism hinduism buddhism atheism
modernism socialism islam is the stand
to supersede all master them all cool
overcome them all
i would like to end my talk
i would like to end my talk with the
quotation of dr adam pearson who said
that people worry
that one day
nuclear weaponry will fall in the hands
of the arabs they fail to realize that
the islamic bomb
the bomb
of the religion of peace has already
been dropped it fell the day prophet
muhammad peace
[Applause]
with us for five minutes of bringing on
all the biggest acts all the key people
that are involved in today's event
and we're gonna end it on the nasheed by
yahya hawaii
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
oh